el norte de china sufre un rebrote de
más de un centenar de casos en una
semana y el gobierno y alertado de que
la situación empeorará en los próximos
días el rebrote se originó en mongolia
interior en grupos de turistas locales y
se ha extendido a 11 provincias el
gobierno ha accionado el protocolo de
alarma y está practicando análisis a la
población de las zonas afectadas también
canceló ayer en el último minuto la
maratón que debía celebrarse en luján el
presunto origen de la pandemia tampoco
se celebrará la maratón que estaba
prevista el domingo que viene en pekín a
pesar de que en la capital sólo se han
detectado cuatro casos a los pequineses
se les ha recomendado que no viajen si
no es totalmente imprescindible a los
llegados de las provincias afectadas se
les exige una pcr negativa realizada en
los dos últimos días china se ha quedado
sola en su estrategia de tolerancia cero
con el virus cuando el mundo está
abriendo paulatinamente sus fronteras y
aceptado convivir con el virus a china
en cambio le preocupa la alta capacidad
de contagio de la nueva variante delta y
no quiere
rebrote le puede arruinar los juegos
olímpicos de pekín que se celebrarán el
año que viene o el congreso del partido
comunista